you'll never know a dear how much I love
you please don't take my sunshine away
Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott's Sun air
just turned one and now the mom of two
is giving us all the feels posting a
sweet Montage of her baby boy's life so
far I'm obsessed with it on Thursday the
makeup Mogul shared this clip to
Instagram giving fans a peek inside
Air's first year that's Kylie with her
little one snuggled up by the pool
checking out the ocean giggling on the
couch swinging on a swing set and get
ready for cuteness overload because that
right there is air lounging by the pool
with his big sister stormy and looking
at her lovingly in the playpen amazing
in the caption Kylie calls air my son my
moon my stars and says his first year is
the best year of her life you complete
Us My Angel mommy loves you may God
always bless you
Kylie baby number two congratulations
Kylie gave fans their first real look at
baby air earlier this month finally
revealing his name Kai and Travis
originally named him wolf Webster a
choice Kylie said she made in a rush
before leaving the hospital why not wolf
and what is the name wolf was never on
our list okay
um it just was actually something Chloe
suggested
I liked the name I don't think anything
I love it I love it I like wolf I just
wasn't him okay so it wasn't against
anything to do with the name it just
wasn't him okay so he's not a wolf but
he is an heir and on Thursday Kylie
celebrated his b day in style with a
cars themed Bash
complete with a huge ball pit themed
balloons and Cake which featured a snap
of air behind the wheel I can't oh but
that's not all yes entered the bash on a
road lined with balloons orange cones
and black and white tassels and just
check out those Wheels yeah air has not
one not two but three fancy Vehicles
it'll be fun okay so safe to say Kylie
knows how to throw an epic bash thank
you and she's the reigning queen of a
sweet insta video montage you make me
happy you in skies are great you'll
never know a deer how much I love you
please don't take my sunshine away
the other night dear As I Lay sleep
[Music]